i think you're going to be quite blown
away
how broad
vitamin d affects
the different organs the different
tissues typically when we think about
vitamin d we think about bone
maybe the immune system but actually
you're going to be quite surprised on
the different areas that vitamin d
affects it's actually
quite fascinating now vitamin d
receptors are
in
almost every single cell if not every
single cell of your entire body and
because vitamin d is a fat soluble
vitamin
it penetrates the membrane and goes
right to the
center of the cell the nucleus okay so
it has
huge effects over that cell and in
reality though vitamin d is not really a
vitamin it's a hormone and it's been
extensively studied
just pubmed just doing a real quick
search on pubmed there's over 64 000
studies
or reviews on vitamin d so there's a lot
of people that looked at this vitamin
extensively and i think it's the most
important fat soluble vitamin of any of
the other vitamins in fact three to four
percent of our genome
is influenced by vitamin d and what's a
genome genomes are the all the genes in
your body um which are all tightly
packaged if we took your genes and
unraveled them and extended them in a
long series of like a string it would go
from here to the moon and back so we
have a lot of genes and three to four
percent of those genes are influenced by
vitamin d so check this out i'm going to
go through all the different um
tissues and body parts and tell you a
little bit about how vitamin d
influences these parts of your body
let's start with the brain
if you're deficient in vitamin d
you're not going to sleep at night
vitamin d helps the circadian rhythm it
helps the sleep centers in your brain
and that center is called the super
charismatic nucleus not that you need to
know that but it's kind of a cool word
so whether you have sleep apnea
or you just have insomnia
or you get up in the middle of the night
because you have high cortisol like a
two o'clock
vitamin d can greatly help you and i
would recommend taking vitamin e before
bed vitamin d
majorly influences the cognitive part of
your brain like the part of the brain
that helps you remember things and that
helps you concentrate i mean in
alzheimer's parkinson's dementia there's
always a vitamin d deficiency and then
we have your mood your mood is greatly
influenced by vitamin d think about in
the winter what happens you have
seasonal affective disorder you have
depression why because you don't get the
sun you don't get the vitamin d and then
you get depressed you get the blues
you're sad i mean think about how
important vitamin d must be to your body
if you can convert sun
through your skin and make your own
vitamin d from the cholesterol lining in
your tissue i mean you don't need to eat
anything to get vitamin d you just need
to expose your skin
to sun so if you have anxiety or you're
especially depressed you need to take
more vitamin d and it will definitely
raise your mood and it can also help
your memory as well all right now what
about hair if you're deficient in
vitamin d
your hair is going to be very dry it's
going to be brittle you're not going to
be able to produce the numbers of hair
because the growth of hair is dependent
on vitamin d you may have early grain
you may experience hair loss during
stress that's a certain condition or
hair loss during menopause or you may
develop an autoimmune disease alopecia
and that can cause these patches of your
hair to fall out so if you can control
the inflammation you can control the
disease and vitamin d is probably one of
the most
potent anti-inflammatories or natural
anti-inflammatories and then we have
your scalp of your hair if you're
deficient in vitamin d you'll be more
predisposed to getting psoriasis
and even eczema on your skin and so now
let's just talk about the skin in
general
people that get acne are usually always
low in vitamin d it can decrease
inflammation on your skin
it can help prevent vitiligo where you
have
this whitening or a lack of pigment
on your skin people with vitiligo
are always deficient in vitamin d if
you're low in vitamin d your risk for
getting skin cancer like melanoma goes
dramatically up all right now what about
the sinuses
yes the sinuses all have receptors for
vitamin d and then if you're deficient
in vitamin d you can have a stuffy nose
you can have sinusitis and the reason
why the vitamin d is in the nose is to
protect you against viruses that are
coming in through the nasal passages and
so we need vitamin d for the immune
system which is the next thing we want
to talk about the thymus gland which is
right on top of the heart is the
training camp for your t-cells and uh as
you age
your thymus gland shrinks and so does
your immune system so the thymus gland
desperately needs vitamin d
to help virtually every part of your
immune system every part of the immune
system has vitamin d receptors so you
have the b cells the t cells you have
both the innate immune system which
you're born with as well as the acquired
immune system needs vitamin d as well
vitamin d helps control the cytokine
storm it helps control certain
autoimmune diseases developing it helps
control the self-attack which is
involved in autoimmune disorders
it's an immune modulator so it helps
buffer uh an over-reactive immune system
that's why it's good for allergies as
well and it also helps keep viruses in
check it decreases the risk of getting
viral infections so as far as the immune
system vitamin d is the most important
nutrient then we have the eyes right
if you're
susceptible to getting cataracts vitamin
d can help slow down that process
vitamin d deficiencies are associated
with macular degeneration glaucoma and
especially
dry eyes now as far as the thyroid which
is located right in on your neck right
through here about two and a half inches
wide
the most common thyroid condition is
hashimoto's like 90
of
all hypothyroid type conditions is
autoimmune it's hashimoto's and like i
said before vitamin d is the best
natural remedy for any autoimmune
problem at all because it drops
inflammation and if you didn't have
inflammation
when you had any type of autoimmune
disease your complications the side
effects would be very minimal because
the side effects occur because of this
autoimmune your body is attacking itself
so hashimoto's
and
graves disease
both autoimmune one's a hypo once a
hyper problem with the thyroid can
greatly benefit from vitamin d all right
what about the teeth well if you're
deficient in vitamin d you're not going
to drive the calcium into the bone
and your teeth are bone made from
calcium and so we need vitamin d to
regulate that calcium and so
if you're deficient
in vitamin d
as a little child or even when you're a
baby inside your mother and you're
deficient in this vitamin d
unfortunately you can develop all sorts
of bone malformations
later in life or even earlier in life as
problems with um the maxillary bone so
you have an overbite or an underbite or
you have um
you're gonna need braces because your
teeth are crooked or you might have
missing teeth
but it doesn't just affect your teeth it
affects the entire skeletal system
you're more susceptible to getting
scoliosis which isn't like an s-curve of
your spine or a hunchback which is
kyphosis
or an exaggerated low back curve which
is lordosis
or even flat feet
or bowed legs which is rickets so
without vitamin d
the bone is softer and it it malforms
i mean this can be devastating for a
child the way they look their confidence
and then later in life if they get
surgery
on their overbite or underbite that's
traumatic i saw some videos recently on
that and i had a hard time watching
these
videos of literally cutting into your
your bone and removing your face and
repositioning and
screwing things back in to make sure
that the face is now symmetrical and the
bite is correct and not to mention
wearing braces for years
so all of this can be
majorly prevented
if that
mother gets enough vitamin d early on
when she's
pregnant if she's breastfeeding and so
hopefully that child is getting enough
vitamin d and other nutrients when
they're developing
but you know i had this interesting
story with a patient he was a medical
doctor and he came in
not by his own accord but his wife
pretty much forced him to come in
because his symptom was hot flashes and
his wife got relief from hot flashes
coming in to see me when i was in
practice so her husband had hot flashes
uh and he came in
and uh to get help
now he was a medical doctor and what he
did is delivered babies and so i asked
him about prenatals i said now do you
recommend um like a whole food prenatal
or
or what because he said there is no
difference between synthetic and natural
they're both the same
and i said oh okay so
where did you learn that he said well in
school this is what they taught us i
said i said is it possible that that
information is
not true is it possible
that's false information he goes he
started looking at he goes well
i don't think they would teach us any
false information
and i said well did you realize that
majority of synthetic vitamins out there
are produced by pharmaceutical companies
did you know that he goes no i didn't
know that i said and is it possible that
the pharmaceutical companies
could
i don't know influence
certain data
that is taught in medical school is it
possible
he goes uh yeah yeah it's definitely
possible i said also the studies on
antioxidants
they always use synthetic versions of an
antioxidant and the studies show that it
increases risk for cancer taking
antioxidants but they what they don't
focus on is the type of antioxidant
they're not using antioxidants that are
coming from food
they're using the synthetic versions i
mean here you are you get the study you
read this data and you go oh
antioxidants cause cancer i'm not going
to recommend it but they don't
differentiate does it come from food
or does it come from
a lab so eventually as we were talking i
kind of got him to look at a new
viewpoint with synthetics versus natural
things and i
i think it's the most important action
for a
woman who's pregnant to get the right
nutrients
because if you're just deficient in one
vitamin vitamin d
that child can end up with
major skeletal malformations later in
life and it can be totally avoided by
making sure that the diet is correct and
making sure that those nutrients are
high quality and not some synthetic
prenatal that comes from petroleum so
anyway we eventually did help him with
his hot flashes and
he started to recommend a higher quality
prenatal but the teeth are highly
influenced by vitamin d as well as
calcium
i remember even as a child growing up i
craved butter i could eat an entire
pound of butter in one sitting little
did i know
what was in that butter there was
vitamin d in there but there is also
vitamin k2 and vitamin k2 works with
vitamin d especially in the formation of
the strength of your teeth and your
bones and unfortunately i was living on
sugar and didn't get my butter fix and i
pretty much ended up with cavities in
every single tooth in my skull but it
just goes to show you the importance of
the right nutrition as you're developing
all right now what about the lung is
vitamin d important for the lung
absolutely
asthma can be improved very quickly in a
child if they're out in the sun playing
so vitamin d just helps open up the
lungs and asthma it's great for
lung infections pneumonia bronchitis
any type of inflammatory condition in
your lung vitamin d should be at the top
of the list also vitamin d keeps viruses
in remission and is awesome for things
like copd
and even cancer of your lungs all right
now let's shift to the muscles
i mean muscles desperately need vitamin
d if you don't have enough vitamin d
your muscles are not going to recover
after exercise there you're going to get
muscle cramps why because vitamin d
helps control calcium and calcium is
involved in the contraction and
relaxation of your muscles and so it
might not be an electrolyte that's
causing your cramps it could be the
vitamin that helps you absorb one of
these electrolytes and you also need
magnesium when you take vitamin d they
both work together and magnesium is also
very important in muscle physiology so
to get rid of achy muscles or cramping
muscles or
weak muscles you need vitamin d
all right now what about your adrenal
glands i mean the main hormone on the
outer portion of your adrenal glands
which is called the cortex is cortisol
and cortisol works very similar to
vitamin d they both are powerful
anti-inflammatories they both help your
immune system
and if you have high levels of cortisol
you're going to also need more vitamin d
so vitamin d is very very important in
the adrenal glands and helping the
adrenal glands to work
if you have high levels of cortisol
you're going to lose vitamin d and the
demand for vitamin d goes straight up
and vertical all right now what about
the pancreas yes especially the cells
that make insulin called the eyelids of
langerhan
these beta cells
require vitamin d to make
insulin
and if you have an autoimmune disease
like in type 1 diabetes
it could have been set up or your body
can be very susceptible to getting that
condition if you're low in vitamin d
and if you have the condition vitamin d
is very very important in keeping
inflammation
as low as possible now what about the
heart a huge association between
coronary heart disease and low vitamin d
vitamin d helps keep the inflammation
low inside your coronary arteries also
the topic on high blood pressure vitamin
d is one of the best things to drop
blood pressure if you have high blood
pressure
i will guarantee you're low in vitamin d
and so that's one of the big benefits
from taking vitamin d is to help you
lower your blood pressure which can then
have effects on helping decrease your
risk of getting a stroke
and also it can decrease your risk of
having
other problems with the kidney and with
the heart all right now what about your
liver well without vitamin d
your risk for insulin resistance goes
higher and so many people have insulin
resistance vitamin d helps insulin in
absorbing other nutrients as well
especially calcium there's a high
association with low vitamin d when you
have a fatty liver and there's
definitely a high association if you
have a if you have inflammation in your
liver as in hepatitis with low vitamin d
so if you have inflammation in any organ
especially the liver you need to be
taking more vitamin d now with the
kidney
you're more susceptible getting stones
if you're low in vitamin d
and the kidney is one of the last
stops for vitamin d in its conversion so
if you have any kidney damage you're not
going to be able to convert vitamin d as
well but realize that all of your cells
have the capacity to convert into the
active form of vitamin d but the kidney
plays a big part in this conversion of
making the inactive into the active
form of vitamin d so many people have
irritable bowel syndrome they have
ulcerative colitis they have crohn's and
diverticulitis any inflammation in the
gut can be greatly improved with vitamin
d and if that inflammation
continues it creates leaky gut so
there's gaps in the
intestine and then you start developing
autoimmune diseases allergies
and all sorts of sensitivities to
certain things both food and
environmental if you're low in vitamin d
your prostate could enlarge
you can have problems with the ovaries
and the testicle the other real
great thing about vitamin d it can help
your joints whether you have stiffness
pain
inflammation
you need vitamin d because vitamin d is
a natural anti-inflammatory it gets rid
of pain and it's especially important in
all the itis like arthritis both
rheumatoid and osteo and of course i
initially mentioned the importance of
vitamin d and bone health but if you're
deficient in vitamin d
you can have osteomalacia which is
softening of the bone that's where the
bones can start to malform especially
early on in life then osteopenia which
is kind of like a pre-osteoporosis
and then actual osteoporosis where the
bones are becoming very very thinned and
they're losing the density and so one
indication to know that you are
deficient in vitamin d is just to press
on your sternum okay your breastbone
here or on your shin and if you have
pain
that's a good way to know you are
deficient because lacking vitamin d
causes bone pain and especially pain in
your lower back even myself i remember
last winter
boy i had some low back pain and then i
i remembered about vitamin d and i
started taking vitamin e and it's
completely
gone within probably two hours so i hope
you now understand the importance
of vitamin d for virtually
every part of your body but i also now
want to introduce you to vitamin k2
which is also needed when you're taking
vitamin d3 i put that video right here
check it out
you